tell us specifically first why did they
stop the production and the F
twenty-twos I mean how many are out
there flying around right now well the
military has right now about 183 not all
of those are fitted for combat it's
about 130 to 140 but it's really a small
fleet in the grand scheme of what you
take to war so part of the problem was
that the plane was just such a really
big burden on the budget that at the
time President Obama and his Defense
Secretary Robert Gates said this is just
not an affordable program for us problem
is sunk costs right Justin because I
mean it's a lot of the money has already
been spent on R&D for this is it not
better to go ahead and build some more
and then of course you're creating jobs
too well the line was shut down after
the last one was delivered and that was
in early 2012 so what's happened since
then is that the the Pentagon has really
focused its effort on a newer plane the
f-35 lightning ii which is an aircraft
that is designed for the marines the
Navy and the Air Force all three and it
comes in three variants and that's
that's the plane that's really gotten
the bulk of the budget right now and you
know the latest that tally is that
that's going to fly for another 50 years
or so okay but Lockheed Martin makes
both is that right they meant both they
do make bolts Brad so how would that
work well what would happen is that you
would probably see money siphoned from
the f-35 program if we went back to
building the f-22 and Lockheed won't
comment on this topic but it's probably
a safe bet that they do not want to see
the f-35 budget messed with it this time
it's a program that's gotten a lot of
criticism the plane is delayed the plane
has had some some operational problems
so it's a case where they really need to
focus on the f-35 at this time and you
know in the grand scheme they have 22
coming back is a real long shot yeah you
know what's cool about it is that also
isn't it right Justin that there's parts
of this plane they were classified right
so we don't know I mean some of the feet
a lot of these features we don't even
know right right I mean a lot of it is
classified for example the top speed is
you know guests have but nobody really
knows I mean
it is definitely a plane that is more
advanced than anything else out there
that flies in combat at the same time
I mean part of the argument has been do
we need this aircraft are there threats
and you know I think what you're seeing
now in the House subcommittee language
is somebody saying yeah in fact Russia's
aggressive China is making some moves
maybe there is a threat so you know it's
an interesting question do these
aircraft to get you know progressively
more technologically better if you like
because you would imagine the f-35 is
just better quote-unquote than the f-22
so why would it need to come back right
well the f-35 has some technologies that
the f-22 doesn't but in terms of its
maneuverability and the agility and some
of the stealth technology it probably is
a better aircraft but at the same time
it's it's a bit more expensive and the
the decision has been made for Inc Lee
there are more than 2,400 f-35s on the
order book that the Pentagon is buying
the f-22 has been shut down to really
change the the math on that it's going
to take a big big big pull in Congress
well and I guess it doesn't affect where
the jobs are either
right if it's not like one factories
goes down another factory is open
they're all the same they're all the
same areas right we're all talking about
US taxpayer money and at the end of the
day the defense budget would have to
probably if you want to build both of
these planes at the same time I mean
you're talking about a major expansion
at a time when that's probably a very
very large thing to try to get through
Congress